all right thank you rocky tomorrow at
the south point there's a huge car and
truck show it's for a great charity
we'll talk about in one second here is
paulette paulette tell everyone what's
happening tomorrow at the south point
yeah so tomorrow is the southpointe car
and truck show it's in the exhibit hall
it's inside yay for air conditioning
it's inside it's 10 a.m to 6 p.m it's
free to spectators so community viewers
please come down it's free bring your
families there's vendors there's food
there's music there's my god gorgeous
vehicles like this you're going to see
all the money stays local to help local
children in need and that's why we're
here today to promote it we appreciate
the extra plug oh we love it let's walk
down here uh i'm going to talk about the
charity in a second uh what kind of car
you're the owner what kind of car is
this yeah this is a 49 mark it's it's
gorgeous why pink was that the original
color why did you go with paint i
actually picked this one up pink oh did
you yeah i usually build cars but this
one we picked up like this
it's a beautiful ride i think i think we
look great riding this thing after the
show
now this all benefits tomorrow the car
show the speedway children's charities
and what do you guys do yes so all the
money that's raised all year round
including in this car show stays local
people to help local kids in need so
whether it's medical financial social we
we get funds together and we grant we
give grants to different children's
charities at the end of the year to help
them if they need food bedding camps you
name it we're there to help them you
guys do amazing things lance get a shot
i've set inside this vehicle i'm going
to talk to the owner sir what's your
name and what kind of car is this my
name is tom engel this is actually 13
different cars but the base is a 37
studebaker now this is no 37 studebaker
because if you saw on the inside do you
have navigation in here i do and then
also i notice the motor if you've got an
ls motor inside this thing if you don't
know cars that means that is a very
powerful engine well it not only has a
ls motor it has a jaguar front end 2000
xj8 and it also has a two thousand gto
brew around independent suspension round
and thirteen other cars this is
beautiful now paula this is just a taste
of the cars we'll see out there tomorrow
how many cars in total there are a few
hundred cars that are going to be out
there so we're cars and trucks i should
say it's presented by star nursery we're
so thrilled to be here to promote it and
again it's free to the public so bring
your families out 10 a.m to 6 p.m
tomorrow at the south point beautiful
thank you paul that real quick sir how
many horsepower in your car 485. let's
go racing afterwards check out the car
show tomorrow at the south point in las
vegas now we'll be right back